do I look like Queen Amidala doodoo no
I'm Amidala right
I was really excited to hear about the
covergirl collection if only because it
allows us fangirls to get a little bit
more nerdiness into our purses and into
our bathrooms it's no longer just like
hey look a Barbie line it's like hey
Star Wars okay let's do this this is
definitely like a cloudy metallic grey
public hue skin gray Ninian Falcon gray
oh god I'm a tooth because that's why I
don't wear makeup no nothing special if
it looks off it's pretty opaque on my
arm
it's very metallic and shiny I look like
I was stranded on ha you'd have to wear
a base and layer this over it I guess if
I was gonna give this color a name it
would be like tonton innards lilac look
the skies with cooler Suns I don't know
I keep this guy B every color once again
metallic kind of not really for my skin
color but let's see maybe I'll be
surprised it's a little slushy but you
know what I could totally make this work
I definitely wish they had names though
like this one is 100% Mara Jade I'm
gonna go with Jar Jar Binks if you can
all the Telex I've noticed so far so
hopefully this one's metallic too there
was love I'll be disappointed I feel
like I'm applying some sort of like
honey looks like an autumn sunset on my
lips when I would much rather look like
creepy oh okay this is super pretty
this is almost to par with some other
metallic old sticks that I own I feel
like it just blends in with my skin
color it's cool it's metallic definitely
is a base though obviously I'm gonna
name it c-3po it's gold it's like the
suns of Tatooine like Palpatine's red
guard in that one movie and then it's
guard like went away we never saw them
again but they were pretty cool Reds can
be kind of tricky oh this is pretty
I actually really like this color wow
this is not going on nicely I'm not
allowed to wear red the other thing
about metallics is basically glitter
oddly I like this this could easily be
named like blood stripe or Slave Leia
Darth Maul that's its name I was gonna
say purple was gonna be like Mace
Windu's my favorite I want to call this
like senator Amidala after her purple
costume that I love so much halloween is
coming up I love wearing super dark
colors oh yeah this is so dark it
doesn't really go on smoothly it's gonna
be a pretty color once I finally get it
in
you're a little outside the walls oh
good I'm gonna call it Alderaan okay so
now I'm moving on to the mascaras there
are ten different sayings but there are
only two different kinds of mascara so
waterproof and not waterproof I feel the
good meal that's a little dirty may the
force be with you
indeed you are powerful it's like you
wake up in the morning put it on and go
take on the world they just all could
have been lightsabers so there could've
been like a neon blue and neon red and
the on green a neon purple if you want
to collect 1 through 10 do it cuz you
guys are real nerds you will collect all
the things this is actually really
really good it's a good mascara I can
see in my youth of loving to collect
stuff I would be like I need all 10 of
these what stuff was gonna die
I liked the year you know targeting us
nerd girls I wish I had more colors for
people like me it's cool just to know
that they're marketing something for a
female fan I am just proud to know that
fangirls are being represented